Speaker 1: This next story is it's unbelievable.
And yet it's predictable because it's Florida.
Florida has suspended a public health official,
a doctor, for encouraging his own staff to get
vaccinated. It's insane and it's dystopian. NPR
reports. Florida Department of Health confirms
Dr. Raul Pino put on leave for encouraging
Orange County Department of Health employees
to get vaccinated didn't require anybody to get
vaccinated. Encouraged people to get vaccinated.
And he has been suspended. The Florida Department
of Health medical director that oversees areas of
Orange County, including Orlando, has been put on
leave for encouraging encouraging his own staff to
get vaccinated. Orange County Medical Director Dr.
Raul Pino wrote an email to staff on January 4th,
encouraging them to get vaccinated and boosted for
COVID. In it, he wrote, quote, I'm having a hard
time understanding how we can be in public health
and not practice. It makes perfect sense. Sensible
Down to Earth statement After sending the email,
he was placed on administrative leave. In an
email to WMP, Florida Department of Health
confirmed he was on leave because quote the
decision to get vaccinated is a personal choice
that should be free from coercion and mandates
from employers. Now encouraging is not demanding.
It is not coercion. It is not a mandate. It is not
offering a consequence if you fail to do it. It's
just, hey, you know, like we're in public health
and there's these vaccines and they're very good
at keeping people alive when they get COVID and
we should really get them. But it's kind of weird
that we work in public health. Whoa. People need
to be free from mandates. Also, dystopian Florida
Department of Health says it's even conducting an
inquiry into whether any laws were broken by
sending the email. Republican Gov. Ron DeSantis
has banned vaccine mandates in the workplace,
and the state has seen a surge in Akron cases.
What's what? And also remember that before it
became politically inconvenient to Ron DeSantis,
Ron DeSantis was encouraging vaccination. More
recently, DeSantis was asked if he's boosted,
and he didn't even want to answer the question,
and the encouragement of vaccination has stopped.
But when it was a different political
situation, when it was, Trump made the vaccines,
and let's go get them. Ron DeSantis had a very
different outlook, and at the end of the day,
Ron DeSantis is determined to spread COVID as
far and wide as possible into the nooks and
crannies of the state of Florida. And what's
the if saying, Hey guys, since we practice
public health, we should actually practice it
and get vaccinated? No mandate, no coercion,
no threat of firing. But we should probably do it.
That now is not allowed, de facto because he was
placed on administrative leave. What's going to
be next? You go to the pharmacy. Hey, by the way,
you're picking up your pills. Did you know that we
have vaccines available and they're free to you?
Did you want to get what have you been vaccinated?
Whoa, that's coercion. Pharmacists shouldn't even
be allowed to do that. That's the next step.
When you say this, action by Dr. Raul Pino
deserves a suspension, which of course it doesn't.
And we'll see whether he is ultimately fired,
whether he comes back with some kind of reprimand,
whether he quits or whatever the case may be.